domestic travel has returned to
pre-pandemic levels
but with the spread of the virulent
delta variant and the low rates of
vaccination in many states
this has become a threat rather than a
cause for celebration
despite pressure from the travel
industry the white house says
existing restrictions on travel from
abroad
will be maintained the more
transmissible delta variant is spreading
both here and around the world
driven by the delta variant cases are
rising here at home particularly among
those who are unvaccinated
and appear likely to continue in the
weeks ahead in new york a covert 19
vaccination will become mandatory for
all the city's 350
000 workers those who refuse will have
to wear masks when at work
and also be tested once a week in
september everything's going to come
together
september is the pivot point of the
recovery september is when many
employers are bringing back
a lot of their employees september is
when school starts full strength
september is when people come back from
the summer september
is when it will all happen the greatest
surge of infections
is in states with the lowest rates of
vaccination
and some districts are not waiting for
stake guidance to take action
the city of saint louis in missouri is
reintroducing a mask mandate
despite significant opposition from some
elected officials mass can become a
symbol of a political divide in our
country
but they're not a bridge too far as some
might say rather
they put the virus in the slow lane and
give us time
to get more people vaccinated and on a
national level more than 50 medical
organizations have issued a joint
statement
saying a vaccine should be federally
mandated
for all health professionals within
hours of veteran affairs department
became the first federal body to
formally issue
a vaccine mandate for its more than a
hundred thousand health care workers
a sign the biden administration is
prepared to flex its muscle
in combating covert 19 despite the real
political risk
of being accused of federal overreach
mike hanna al-jazeera washington